your DNA contains all the information
needed to make your body in this DNA our
genes which code for vital proteins but
your genes are also full of gaps these
gaps known as introns are sections which
don't code for proteins but they're
found scattered throughout all sorts of
genes and in all sorts of creatures so
what exactly at introns for that is an
ongoing question imagine we want to
translate the DNA in a particular gene
into a protein first we need to make a
copy of the gene in RNA like the
original gene this RNA sequence is still
full of introns and these need to be cut
out before the RNA can be translated
into a protein
this cutting or splicing is done by
spliceosomes
which helps snip the introns out and
stick the remaining bits back together
this final spliced RNA sequence is what
gets turned into proteins
but why bother with introns at all all
that extra transcribing and splicing
takes energy so why is it so common one
key benefit of RNA splicing is that you
can rearrange sections of a gene in
different ways this means one gene can
make multiple different proteins now a
lot of the time the introns themselves
get immediately degraded by the cell but
scientists have identified cases where
the introns hang around for example some
introns help protect DNA from damage
while others can speed up gene
expression now research on yeast cells
has suggested a potential new function
for introns making proteins takes a lot
of energy so when a cell is strong
or hungry it may want to slow down
protein production one way of doing this
is to slow down the splicing process and
it looks like introns themselves could
be helping control splicing speed when
spliceosomes are slowed there's less
spliced RNA and fewer proteins can be
made in yeast this kind of system might
be helping cells control their growth
and survive starvation whether something
similar is going on in humans is yet to
be seen but as time goes by introns
are revealing more and more of their
secrets helping us piece together a
greater understanding of the incredible
genetic complexity of life
[Music]